bill shaiken covers the dodgers for the
la times covers baseball for the l.a
times and he's kind enough to join us
bill what did you expect last night
between these two teams after what
happened the previous night
seen any game and a season when you know
the x-rating rule is supposed to get us
home pretty early
what happened with uh joe kelly and i'm
curious the reaction by the dodgers once
they heard the suspension
well they weren't thrilled no team is
ever thrilled to have one of its players
suspended but
i think it goes back to everything
that's happened over the past few months
because when rob manfred issued the
suspensions
he was like you know the usual corporate
executive everything's under control
here's the report read what you want to
find out let's move on let's
go forward and that might have worked
until the astros had their fan festival
in the winter and the dodgers were kind
of keeping an eye on that the players
were
because they wanted to see how
remorseful the astros might be
and the dodgers watched the clips from
houston
they certainly did not see any remorse
in
the comments that they saw on television
that the astros made
and so when the dodgers had their fan
festival the next weekend
they let the astros have it and then
people thought
okay great it's done we'll go to spring
training the astros will
have a press conference they'll
apologize and as we might remember from
the pre-pandemic era
the astros had a completely disastrous
press conference in which
the owner refused to take any
accountability the players are like you
know it's done we're not talking about
it
and so everybody's been sort of waiting
and at one point
in again the pre-pandemic spring
training
rob manfred had a press conference and
he said you know i think what's going to
happen it's not so much that i haven't
punished the astros it's that they'll be
shamed and they'll be shamed as you've
even heard
in spring training games and there were
dodger fans there was a group of 3
000 dodger fans that had bought tickets
to come
boo the astros in anaheim they didn't
care about the angels
they just wanted to go boo the astros
because the astros and dodgers remember
were not supposed to play this season
well now there's no fans in the ballpark
so what happens how do the dodgers get a
chance to say
uh we remember and yeah we're not going
to forget that easily
why joe kelly
joe kelly is joe kelly and as
major league baseball's uh press release
yesterday noted he has a history of
throwing inside i believe is how they
put it so he came out and
you know i think he might have escaped
such draconian punishment had he not
thrown balls toward three separate
houston hitters
and i'm sure he will go to major league
baseball and say well you know i'm
paying for a pro-rated salary so how
about a pro-rated suspension right you
know
you gave me six games a couple years ago
and they were 162. now you're giving me
eight out of 60.
but you know kelly's guy who you know
despite
whatever you would say publicly
obviously took some pride in standing up
for his teammates and
you could tell by the reaction of the
dodgers players they were certainly not
embarrassed by it
yeah and this is based off intent though
bill that's what's interesting so
just the intent of throwing or trying to
hit somebody is
why he got it feels like the
commissioner's still protecting the
astros
by saying if you do this this is the
punishment you face here
but it's not he didn't hit anybody he
didn't hit anybody but
they looked at a history and look if joe
kelly had thrown one pitch high and
inside
maybe it's different he threw inside to
three separate houston players
he threw high and inside to two you know
other than a lie detector test i think
the video is probably
where you say one pitch slip but four
oh i agree he needed to be suspended for
it especially if you throw up towards
the head
i have no patience for that whatsoever
but i'm curious
dave roberts got one game why did dave
roberts get
one game uh league said that was because
of
kelly's actions so clearly when rob
manfred was telling the public
go ahead and shame the astros that'll be
their punishment
he was telling teams even back then i do
not want a festival of retaliation
and here it is the first week of the
season and we don't know how many weeks
this season
ultimately will last but if it goes nine
weeks and if it goes through 16 teams in
the playoffs
major league baseball wanted to make a
point very clearly that
whatever feelings you have about the
houston astros please do not express
them
with 95 mile an hour baseball
all right so now we move to september
when the astros come to
have have the dodgers move past this in
your opinion
probably at this point i think they've
they've made their feelings known
loud and clear nothing is going to
happen beyond that
and of course as as we've learned in the
past 24 hours i think
the athletic had at first that the
protocols now have been changed because
rob manfred said you know my hands were
tied
because the only way i was going to get
the information from the astros players
was to promise them immunity for their
testimony because i had already issued a
memo that said
the responsible parties are the manager
and the general manager
and remember those guys are fired by the
astros
going forward enough players said this
is ridiculous
that the league and the union got
together and said yeah this is
ridiculous
and if this happens again players will
be subject to discipline
yeah i just wondered if you had former
players since that's how this all
started
a former player is the one that had the
story about the astros
could you have granted them any kind of
immunity or you probably didn't even
need to do that
where you could have punished the astros
and
that was what was surprising that he had
to he had to give them immunity to get
this information
felt like it was there um for the taking
well the trouble is and the league found
this out
a long time ago when they investigated
steroids in the mitchell report
you can compel a coach or a manager or a
club executive
to do an interview you can't compel a
player because they're represented by
the players union
so the george mitchell report had a ton
of holes
not through anybody's fault on the
mitchell team
but because he said i've got all this
information
i'm gonna present what i have but i
asked the players to corroborate to sit
for an interview to tell me what i got
wrong
and they just wouldn't do it and i think
manfred needed to make sure look
i've got one guy i don't know his
motivation maybe he's
a truth seeker maybe he's a disgruntled
ex-employee who
obviously isn't playing for the astros
anymore i need to corroborate this
information
and that's what he had at the time and
again going
forward that won't be the pattern but
that's what they had and that's what
they did
i thought oral horseshies had a great
line last night was that when el touve
uh struck out and yeah
then he said it's tougher when you're
guessing than when you're knowing
what's coming yeah
the dodgers television station which is
uh
actually a t-mone station was uh quite
uh
in mr kelly's corner over the last
couple days and rightfully so these are
you know employees that are number one
paid by the team but more importantly
these are guys that have played the game
they're respected guys like oral
nomar garciaparra jerry hairston jr and
usually you try and modulate what you
have to say a little bit but they were
no holds barred you know you're a dodger
fan and these guys are in your corner
and uh
frankly a lot of people around baseball
thought that joe kelly was in the right
because if you looked on social media
yesterday
it wasn't just dodger guys that were
coming out to support him as
people like marcus strowman you know
phil hughes jared weaver like
guys who have been there that said you
know this is ridiculous
if he didn't buzz the tower bill if you
just hit somebody in the backside
i mean you accomplish what you want to
accomplish don't you
you do um now i know joe said after the
game that there was a widely circulated
video during the time that the game was
shut down
he was at home working on a pitch try to
hit the hank aaron pitchback and he
broke his window
so you know maybe his control isn't
always the best
you know i don't think short of truth
serum you're ever going to find out
really how intentional it was but again
you had three batters and four pitches
and
and that was certainly enough for the
league if i ask
the residents of los angeles you can
have the dodgers when the world series
or the lakers win the nba title
this year
well if you can assure me that we can
get enough people together to have a
parade maybe i have an idea but since
we're just gonna have to sit at home and
watch on zoom anyway
i'm not sure which one would be better
but
let's just say there have been a few
lakers parades in this town since the
last time the dodgers
won in 1988 the grainy black and white
kirk gibson videos are great but we've
seen enough of them
and frankly you know as players like to
say
you never know when you're going to get
this chance again and
and against the astros the dodgers got
to game seven of the world series
and that's as far as the dodgers
franchise has gotten in the last 32
years
good stuff bill as always safe travels
we appreciate your time
all right take care that's uh bill
shaiken he covers the dodgers
baseball for the l.a times